but now it's magnus carlsen it's just to
enjoy the game right you might go it is
simply it's not going to be the favorite
anyway right exactly he's not the
favorite he traditionally doesn't have a
great score against magnus carlsen so
just enjoy the game relax
and it is an experience to save her
after all we have seen magnus go wrong
so be positive exactly
meanwhile it is the spanish opening
something we also call the roy lopez and
this is very mainline this is very
typical we actually saw this position
actually until the last move we saw this
position arise plenty in the world
championship where magnus had the black
pieces this is one of the most historic
openings in chess i think every grand
master at some point has had this
position on the board it's also one of
the first ones we teach young players
because often it's about occupying the
center white will try and push a pawn in
the middle of the board just like eric
did actually in the last game and then
from there it's about planning it's
about placement of pieces and a lot of
tension there won't be many exchanges
early in this game
and uh okay meanwhile eric thinking i'm
expecting to see him bring his knight
actually to the side of the board to hit
white's light-squared bishop to try and
trade that one off that's what he played
yesterday in one game and eric he's
actually a big expert from the white
side as well of this position so really
interesting to see the psychology at
play both sides have had this position
plenty of times with white with black
and uh
yeah magnus he's uh kind of served with
both hands so far he played very
different openings on the first two days
to the opening seas started playing
today
that just shows flexibility and that's
what you need at the top level now you
need to surprise your opponent in a way
but you also need to guide it into
territory where you're very comfortable
magnus who we know has been down with
kovid over the last few days hopefully
starting to feel
better what should you do you walk in
when you have had sickness in your house
i mean
does that stick as well to the walls no
i wouldn't say that stick to the walls
but it's always from a psychological
point of view to refresh the air
obviously that's something you usually
do you change the sheets you change the
clothes wash the clothes but also the
air obviously because there's something
about smelling sickness in the air yeah
i know i i i couldn't put
any any any you know information on on
that but a monitor or something that
actually measures the air will
definitely help with identifying if
there's something in the air usually
it's it is a lot of things in the air
because it's it's it's about stale air
if you're laying down if you're sick
you're not moving around and then the
air you know becomes stale and you just
basically fill up that air because
you're just at home yeah you just spend
time in that environment yeah true
that's yeah exactly because you stay
more at home as well when when you are
sick but also with covid i bet that more
people will stay in home office right it
you know the covet is hopefully over now
but still you know i think people enjoy
having home office from time to time so
it must be getting more and more
important as well
for your home environment to have better
air quality because you're probably
gonna spend more time at home absolutely
yeah
all right moves coming out david yep
meanwhile the moves are starting to uh
speed up but eric did spend a couple of
minutes playing a move or thinking about
a move that he played yesterday i mean
he's played plenty of times in his
career maybe that just shows a lack of
confidence from eric doing something
similar to what he did against anishgiri
he hasn't spent that long but he did
definitely pause and he's seen this
position before so it's very surprising
to have that early think those two extra
minutes could have been really useful
later in the game meanwhile black did
bring the knight to the side of the
board as predicted and now we do see a
bit of a clash in the middle with a lot
of tension look at the pawns they are
staring down each other and the main
move here or the move that eric employed
yesterday was to bring his queen
actually just one square as black just
to kind of support his center from afar
so not to touch any pawns not to break
the tension
some trades might happen in the middle
of the board but you want it to be on
your terms you don't want to spend the
time making those trades and actually
freeing up your opponent's position you
want to let them spend their move
exchanging things so i'm expecting to
see eric just maintain the tension right
now either by just moving his queen or
retreating the black knight by the way
he needs to protect his central pawns as
black
um so he needs to move fast as well he's
seen this position plenty of times
before um i think i've actually even
played eric in this position online in
blitz just before um when i was black so
he definitely knows the plans from both
colors and from both sides it's just
surprising to see him even spend a few
seconds
top players like magnus carlsen if they
know the position they'll just play
instantly they trust their instincts
they trust their homework from uh before
but what is what is magnus doing on
eric's time here is he trying to recall
something or is he sleeping
meditating
the thing is though this has all been
played before it's kind of like standard
mainstream stuff i'm not really sure why
eric is thinking so much i mean
it's kind of showing that he's a little
bit nervous a little bit hesitant
maybe he didn't expect this maybe he's
kind of like double guessing himself
overthinking the situation but he has to
just continue with what he's prepared
and play quickly that will that will
definitely put magnus off it's not just
the lack of time that he'll have for
later in the game it's also a sign to
your opponent um i mean for example here
magnus has actually built up a lot of
time on the clock he's got 17 minutes
now he only started with 15 so he's
gained two minutes eric has spent a bit
of time but inside magnus must be
thinking okay he's not confident he's
not familiar with the position that is
only a bonus so you're kind of boosting
your opponent's confidence while burning
your own time it's not a good sign and
meanwhile we did see a trade of one set
of pawns in the center
but now the fight still is about the
middle of the board black's knight
retreated to put some pressure on
white's middle pawns white central pawns
there and white's knight has gone to the
side but it is looking back towards the
center so if we see another trade of
pawns in the middle of the board then
white's knights are ready to pounce to
great squares so
um there's actually a few moves in this
position the most common move i was
about to say is to push this pawn on the
side of the board just to push it one
square further to destabilize white's
knight on the left there i'm expecting
to see eric play that
soon hopefully um because that's the
only logical follow-up to his previous
move if you push a pawn one square you
might as well continue pushing it
and uh once white's knight retreats then
black can decide what to do with his
light squad bishop that's still on its
start square ideally you want to connect
your rooks in every position so black
wants to connect his rooks and then
decide where to put them later in the
game this position is still well known
it's been known for hundreds of years um
so it's uh slightly surprising that eric
is still thinking and head down now just
maybe trying to remember he was a little
frustrated before beginners like joachim
and me is this a
quite instructive game by magnus carlsen
taking center developing pieces and
getting his king to safety yeah the same
themes as the last game actually yeah
white setup is almost identical to what
eric did in the previous game
um black setup is different this time
but uh yeah this is i mean these are the
few things to remember centralize the
pieces of course try and put your pawns
in the middle of the board if possible
but centralize your pieces to back them
up so if the pawns ever get traded or
get eliminated then your pieces are
ready to occupy those squares and
if you look in the middle the four
central squares so on the e and d lines
those four that middle block it's all
about those squares and the reason white
has a small advantage
uh kind of
just traditionally in this type of
position and the reason the computer
slightly prefers white's position is
because white has two pawns in the
middle black only has one um so white is
the one choosing to release the tension
white can push a pawn in the middle to
gain a bit more space kick away a black
knight or white can trade you can just
having that choice normally gives you
the advantage being the one who can
break the tension and for example if
black is the one to take a pawn in the
middle of the board then white's still
occupying the center with one pawn black
having no
no more presence there so yeah it's
difficult to kind of explain the
specifics because it's such a
complicated position everything's still
on the board but in general pawns in the
middle support them with pieces ideally
especially with knights near the center
of the board and then it's time to bring
the rooks towards the center
and you go from there
and eric actually choosing the most
second most popular move here
and this knight move is just a
disruptive move you know it's just
designed to drive the light squared
bishop one square back and just say to
white hey your work and bishop are out
of play
and
one thing that i also want to reinforce
when it comes to this type of strategy
is that
white so santa is ably supported by
pieces but you also have to protect your
defenders of the center so you and take
a look at that little pawn there by the
king on the right side the h pawn it
covers a very critical square the g4
square so it stops a bishop coming to
that square or a knight which would
immediately start attacking the
defenders of the center it's all about
center yeah it's all about the center
and now a bit of maneuvering black's
knight just came to this square it did
earlier hit white's bishop which
retreated but now after magnus's last
move the knight is forced back where it
came from so this knight actually has
moved several times it started on this
square it moved once twice it went back
where it came from and then it went back
and then it went back so i don't know
how many moves that is five six moves
and it's still on a square it was on
much much earlier so a lot of time by
black there were reasons behind that but
ideally he wants to now start
accelerating the play he needs to start
getting these two rooks into the action
so for example bringing one to this
square maybe bring the other to an open
line um if the black knight moves out
the way then the black queen the black
rook will occupy a fully open file and
uh still there is tension white has some
vague threats of hitting this pawn
eventually uh also white is still the
one as we mentioned earlier with the key
to the center because white can take any
time he wants that would be a safety
first approach just to make things
symmetrical or white can gain space for
example if black moves white can push
forward and block things up but white
has the furthest advanced pawn in center
and that gives a long-term advantage so
yeah right now eric's still facing some
problems
i would centralize one of the rooks i'm
not sure which rook right now but uh
those two are the only pieces still not
doing much
he doesn't though he just brings his
queen across one square still a safe
move but now i expect to see magnus try
and do the same with his rooks this is
the worst place piece so in chess you
especially in block positions like this
one you talk to your pieces ask which
one is the most unhappy and you want to
activate this so you need to get the
bishop out the way so the two moves that
come to mind either this bishop move
actually putting it on the same diagonal
as black's king is very tempting or you
bring it this way and put some pressure
on the black pawns and next you
centralize your rooks
try and put them on open lines if you
can and
if you look at this for example white
pieces how much more centralized can you
get these pieces right in the center
these knights supporting the center and
if things open up if these central pawns
do all disappear white pieces are much
more ready than blacks
just in the center of the board yeah and
you've kind of this particular position
has been played before uh it was
actually played by anatoly karpov in
1982
against uh blaster mill hort so it's
fine
it wasn't the last time but it's a
really rare line so magnus doing what
magnus does best you know he goes into
these mainstream lines and then you know
when you're like 10 moves deep he will
go and pick something that hasn't been
played like 40 years ago
and it will still be critical and it
will still pose black some problems and
uh the line that you showed is very very
pleasant for white
yeah and magnus a big student of chess
history that's another thing for
everyone at home to
to go and do now just go check out some
chess books go look on websites like
chess24 there's some video series about
chess history about the former world
champions like karpov and uh just
learning a bit about them learning about
their games teaches you a lot about
strategy and often that gives you an
edge over the modern players who just
play purely on computers just knowing a
bit about what happened in the past can
teach you about what to do in the future
so is it very common to
have these different strategies that you
like go through in your head like you
know that like famous chess players have
done before and you use those to like
map out your strategy yeah definitely
and i think personally the most useful
thing is um just a stylistic thing so
for example i think of myself as well i
used to think of myself as an attacking
player these days i like my slow steady
kind of build up positions where it is
geared towards winning in the end game
tiring my opponent out and then i look
okay i read in the chess book about
karpov for example who had a very
similar style he often won in the end
game and i can base my own play around
these great players so
for example if you're an aspiring
footballer if you're young and you want
to get into football you watch the top
players you learn from them you learn
some techniques you learn some tricks
you learn their positioning that type of
thing and it's the same in chess if you
play through the games of previous
players then you learn what to do what
not to do and it's always nice to have a
role model yeah and yeah and finding
that player that sort of resembles your
style as well if you are a
defensive player in football then
there's no point in studying too much
maybe the striker you want to you want
to have a defensive player as your idol
exactly exactly and it's the same
interests i mean attacking player you
look at mikhail tal or gary kasparov if
you're a defensive player you might look
at patron it's it's quite easy and
from there as well
the most common question i get or one of
the most common is what opening should i
play how do i start the game yeah what
should i aim for at the beginning i just
think okay depending on what you want do
you want attacking position depending on
your style go and look at these top
players see what openings they play and
learn from there and uh for example if
anish geary is your idol you can go and
chess will watch some videos of his if
magnus is your idol go and chess will
watch some videos of his and um yeah
either way there's so many ways to learn
nowadays so isn't the opening the most
easiest part
for the play uh it's easy but there's
always tricks and tracks to avoid so
it's maybe the easiest to learn um when
you're first starting the game but end
games are maybe the most important
yeah so end games no matter how good
your opening is if you
i mean this is why chess is so hard you
might play a perfect game for 80 moves
and if you make a mistake on move 81 you
might lose yeah just one bad move out of
80. it's other sports if you play 80
good minutes in football
i mean sometimes if you have one or two
bad uh about minutes it can affect the
result but most of the time you're in
control yeah you're winning by then
yes it's it's hard so end games i would
say the most important when you're first
starting but openings are the easiest
one to learn ivanka
endings are definitely
a very crucial part of uh chass uh
improvement because they're kind of
essentially signposts because you can
literally go hang on a second
recall this ending i know that was
winning for me so i'm going to steer the
game towards that and uh even if you're
up material for instance euros like hang
on a second
i don't need to engage in all these
complications let's just trade off the
pieces make it simple yeah and uh you
know there are some endings where even
magnus carlsen has no chance of uh
winning or even saving the game
that's what one of my first chess
coaches told me actually he said you
know in russia they teach the end game
first because if you don't know what you
want to aim for at the end then how do
you
map your path uh through the opening a
middle game in the first place so um
yeah i mean obviously there's different
techniques and every phase of the game
is important but end games uh
are definitely the key and meanwhile
finally there have has been kind of a
release of the tension we just on the
last couple of moves sought a trade and
now both sides have a knight on one of
those four central squares in the middle
of the board i prefer white tonight
because the black knight can actually at
some point get hit by one of white's
pawns white at some point if we jump in
can throw a pawn up the board and
destabilize the black knight
for example with this one kicking the
black knight away however the same
cannot be said for black black can never
kick away this knight with a pawn if you
look at the lines next to this knight
there's just no pawn to push um so we
would say that this knight is on an
outpost no point can challenge it
whereas black's knight is slightly less
stable long term so that's why white has
a small advantage also because if you
compare the central pawns this pawn is
on one of the central four squares here
whereas black's pawn is isolated it's
got covered it's isolated
uh yeah it's got no friends around it so
it's potentially long-term a weakness
social distancing well i have to say
this is just uh
this game i'm learning from this game
just about taking center this is exactly
where i would put my pieces just throw
them towards the center and again that's
why we play through old games pattern
recognition you learn what to aim for
and
i'm sure yeah even players who are still
learning or kind of starting out the
game they could reach a position like
this one just on general principles if
you know the basic rules in openings you
can arrive in a position like this what
to do next is of course tricky and the
players are definitely going to find it
tricky as well but uh yeah right now the
players have both done everything right
and it's still very tense
and uh whilst the tense situation
occurs over the board i want to relieve
the atmosphere here and i want to show
you some selfies
and the first one comes from our good
friend
ginger gm simon williams he says oh my
god david
is on tv
that's my night sorted
[Laughter]
and uh then then we have a another
selfie from nod ong putic who says
rooting for prague to win and just
listening to oh that's very nice vank is
lovely accent watching from saudi arabia
thank you very much nad for that
compliment
and asgar says
is watching from minneapolis and
minnesota and i must say that the most
say the puma jacket though is cool on
david
everyone i have seen a lot of
compliments on the on the puma jacket
and some people saying they want some as
well yeah it was weird sitting without
the tie though
yeah like more than a hundred show
you've been in here with your suits and
then suddenly in like a sports jacket
yeah i'm a new man
and one final selfie uh chris bird says
that he's at home in tucson arizona
which by the way has some of the best
quality in air of air in the us oh wow
yeah okay it's important to have a good
air quality because um
okay i'm not maybe not going to make too
many friends here but i went to
christmas i went for christmas to
england to london and i love london it's
like my home city i love it a bit but
when i stepped off the train i was like
[Laughter]
it was like it felt really bad
and i think i've been sport by the
norwegian mountains a little bit yeah
everything is relative
well
you know is there a list of the worst
cities in the world when it comes to
equality not to speak badly of anyone
but you know there there is a list with
the cities that have a lot of pollution
uh for sure um but i tend to focus on
the cities who have actually have good
yeah air quality instead
so what would be a good if you want to
go to a big city for a weekend and have
some good time but you don't want to go
to a place with bad air quality
really also is one of the best air
quality cities well if you go a little
bit north and discover the beautiful
marika yeah and everything that has to
do with that but in general obviously
cities in general have a lot of
combustion from from from cars to
missions
so so in general if you want to
experience really truly good air don't
go to the city i'd say exactly
and uh just a question as well because a
moment ago we saw magnus carlsen's air
quality stats come up and we've talked
about co2 levels we've talked about a
few things but is there a perfect
temperature for a home office or perfect
humidity because the two red circles i
saw in magnus carson's air quality they
were temperature and humidity
did those effects do those affect things
much constantly i can't play in the heat
it's it's it's well we do have this we
have general guidelines that says 22
degrees is is the optimum in office
environments and in home environments
with typical indoor clothes but there's
always going to be 20 of the people uh
depending on the gender depending on
airflow depending on different factors
that's going to say that 22 degrees is
not the optimum air
temperature in there that has to do with
the thermal comfort which has some
divergence uh from people to people but
generally 22 degrees is isn't optimal
you could potentially solve this big
dilemma that we have in chest in the
chest world when it comes to chest
tournaments
uh in test test tournaments normally the
air runs quite cold
and you see the men are very comfortable
but the women are freezing yeah
so what is the ideal temperature for a
woman and a man
uh 22 degrees still 22. 22 degrees uh in
in the end it doesn't matter if you find
an optimum if you do scientific studies
10 20 of the people if it's 10 people
two of the the the 10 people are not
gonna be satisfied anyway yeah okay
regardless yeah so um
22 degrees
oh okay well there's a lesson also to
tournament organizers all over the place
yeah 22 degrees
yeah finally solve that
visual debates i can definitely envision
that in these huge halls and then the
women with like wool scarves are just
freezing and the men are like whew it's
so warm
i played in the tournament once where
where every single woman had their
coat on their scarf
and some of the men who were quite big
actually they were like they're in the
shade t-shirts and we were like not bad
but then it's super important to monitor
deer so you actually know that it is 22
degrees yeah so yeah so then you know so
that old lady in the in the corner
wearing the big you know jacket and all
it's you can you can show the data at
least yeah and that has some
psychological yeah that's true oh okay
so it is 22 degrees okay maybe it is not
that cold
yeah
all right what's happening on the board
david i do hear some pings yeah
meanwhile it's all about maneuvering
right now because actually nothing's
changed in the center of the board both
players just kind of tiptoeing around
it's very very reminiscent as well of
the last game where eric played against
anish giri it feels like the tension is
still bubbling but it's all about
whether he has enough time left on the
clock for when the action actually
starts and
the same move that anish employed
against eric earlier in the last round
has now been used by eric himself he's
maybe learned from what giri did against
him and he's just pushed his b pawn
forward one square he's trying to
distract magnus on this left side of the
board he's trying to open up lines if
you look at the black queen look at the
black rook behind it they're trying to
open up
lines for themselves but magnus he's not
touching that side of the board he's
playing now in the center where his
pieces are where they are stronger and
that's great strategy if you're stronger
on one side of the board play there
ignore your opponent's plans it does
tend to become a race um but if you
touch pawns on your side you're weaker
bad things will happen and uh okay
meanwhile black's knight was attacked in
the center it has now retreated and
eric has six minutes this time things
are heating up uh we see maybe there
will be uh pawn pushes in the center
things will explode open and six minutes
is much better than his previous game
when uh yeah he really really went wrong
quite quickly so
i like what eric is doing despite what
the computer evaluation says i do prefer
white's position but i think black is at
least trying to create some counterplay
on this left side of the board and if he
can break through that magnus won't have
it all his way and isn't he extremely
safe with his king eric hansen yeah
touchable that's one phrase we coined
last season right knights are a king's
best friend those two black knights are
going to act as defenders and they need
to because an attack will brew against
the black king normally actually when a
side occupies the center like white is
doing
that is the launch pad for an attack
against the opponent's king you can very
rarely see an attack being successful if
you don't have central control so okay
magnus
he's been yo-yoing with that bishop back
and forth back and forth the entire game
but look at white's pieces now the
knights the rooks all of them uh after
this pawn push the knight dropping back
magnus now look at this formation four
pieces in a row three pieces in a row
this is
kind of chess strategy 101 and despite
allowing a porn trade here despite
allowing this open line the queen and
rook they're just hitting thin air it's
all about these pieces and
they are poised no matter where the
action happens if it happens on the left
side of the board they're ready if it
happens towards the king side they're
ready and uh that's why centralized
pieces are the best they're just so
flexible and meanwhile black is trying
to create something he is hitting a pawn
now eric
and uh i think there's just nothing else
to do black is set up in a defensive
formation over here as you mentioned
kaya and uh he's just hoping that no
matter what white white's pieces do he
will have time to go and grab this pawn
and if he grabs this pawn then black
spawn suddenly becomes really dangerous
just three squares away from promotion
so not so easy to defend that pawn
either because the move that you would
really love to play is actually just to
pick up the knight that's sitting on the
d2 square and move it to the c4 square
but the problem is that knight is the
key defender of one of white's really
important central pawns
so after a queen trade yeah you
mentioned it yvanka this pawn no longer
defended sufficiently it's attacked
twice it's only defended once so black
can grab it very safely and black
actually would be just a pawn up with a
winning advantage so the move magnus
wants to play as you mentioned not
possible at the moment and there's also
another idea on the board
which is basically that if white goes
okay fine i want to defend that pawn and
maybe i'm going to play the rather
passive rook move all the way um yeah
that looks good looks like everything is
holding tight but take a look at that
night white's pride and joy sitting in
the middle of the board is only defended
once and black is attacking it once so
therefore the old soviet language was
that this is a tactical weakness
and this means that knight takes porn is
impossible yeah and now look at this
bishop it's overworked it wants to be
defending its own knight but it's just
been deflected away to capture black's
night now black's knight just too strong
it's grabbed upon attacking the white
queen so once white recaptures this
knight with the bishop it no longer
defends this knight in the center so
yeah well spotted your anchor that's
actually a second threat and black would
be a pawn up here with a nasty check the
white king actually a bit vulnerable on
this diagonal so black has two threats
in the current position queen takes pawn
but also the very sneaky the hidden
threat of knight takes pawn deflecting
away this overworked bishop
so how does magnus deal with both of
these the one move that i see i mean
it's not a move magnus wants to play but
the only way i see to deal with both of
those
is to retreat this knight defending this
pawn here but also now the knight is no
longer hanging on this square
and maybe now white can aim to use his
bishop on this diagonal partly to attack
the black queen but partly to go towards
the black king later on on this nice
diagonal
seating up it's really heating up and
eric has created two sneaky threats and
it's not easy to deal with them and
magnus he hates retreating i think every
top player hates retreating and if
that's the best move i'm struggling to
find others but if that is the best move
dropping that is the best move
that was the only move to kind of
actually maintain a small advantage
magnus has blundered
he's just forgotten about this threat
he's brought his rook across attacking
the black queen but now knight takes
pawn i think is just winning for black
or at least gives a big advantage and
look at that stockfish the computer
confirms it this move knight takes pawn
knight takes f4 gives black a plus one
advantage just wins the pawn we've got
to check out the player yeah so let's
get out
well look at that eric hanson is now
leaning forward it definitely seems he
is noticing that this is a critical
moment
is magnus carlsen realizing he might
have blundered yeah it looks like it and
i just you can see that eric has leaned
forward pouncing like a puma yeah
i'm sorry
very nice very nice
and these top players have great
instincts his spidey senses will be
tingling he will know there's something
in the position but it's just about
whether he has enough time to calculate
it and sometimes especially when you
play someone like the world champion you
trust them you trust their calculation
you get a bit scared you think these top
players don't make mistakes and then you
just miss your opportunities so it's
psychological here first it's about
seeing the move seeing it's an option
but also trusting himself rather than
magnus yeah i i agree you know because
the first thing here it could be that
he's like rook attacks queen queen moves
that could be like an assumption there
in his thinking and remember one of the
pawns is still up for grabs he could
actually go queen takes pawn and be
calculating and getting excited about
that line completely missing that knight
takes pawn on the agenda even stronger
yeah but actually if we look at the
other moves that the computer suggests
here the top three choices by black
two moves are fine knight takes pawn is
actually very strong and i think
actually that gives a better advantage
than the computer is saying especially
psychologically the second move okay he
finds the best move i was going to say
he could take a pawn with his queen and
that's fine as well but
magnus now reacts instantly it feels
like magnus is bluffing because look at
this last move by the black queen she's
now attacking the bishop next to her and
she's still keeping an eye on both of
the two white knights and white's dark
squared bishop in the center is
defending both of the knights it's
simply overworked black is up a pawn for
free
and uh eric big advantage he's still got
time on the clock as well doing well and
look at the bar now it is really
reacting
saying 2.4 advantage for the chess
dreamer eric hansen it would be a huge
shock to the chess world if he wins this
game with the black pieces magnus
carlson in trouble again yeah magnus i
mean he you can count on one hand the
time of uh the amount of times he loses
with white in a year but yesterday he
lost against pragnando with white he
lost against napoleon with white on the
first day
dangerous times now for the world
champion and he does not seem happy and
full credit to eric for spotting that as
well and going for it and uh it's just
converting this though still a long way
to go still most of the pieces still on
the board
yeah i think i would just be a bit
scared here i would just retreat that
black knight that had
entered white's position that did grab a
pawn i would just step it back not sure
exactly where but a few safe squares
there and black should have the
advantage he does retreat with that
night yeah i agree that's the safe
choice
and especially when you don't have so
much time left on the clock and i'm sure
that uh eric has just had an adrenaline
rush when he's played that knight taste
pawn because you know
before he didn't perhaps contemplate the
idea that he could win against magnus
and now it's on the cards and this is
where players start to get nervous
and both sides keeping a poker face
meanwhile neither side giving much away
if i were magnus if i just lost a pawn
for free i would be
like beating myself up i would just be
shaking my head
do they see each other
that's a very good question they can if
they want to they can have a choice but
i don't think magnus has his camera open
most of the time has the opponent's
camera open most of the time but is this
a thing in in chess where you like
analyze the opponent and and and draw
conclusions based on eye movements and
things like that definitely i mean
david does it all the time right yeah
i'm obsessed with steroids i stare at
the opponent too much i think most of my
opponents get really uncomfortable
they're like why is he looking at me but
uh yeah um definitely when you play over
the boards it's impossible to ignore
what's happening wow what just just
happened there magnus plays bishop takes
pawn whoa he's completely hallucinated
magnus just lost a piece for free and
has he given up he has given up he has
resigned
that you will never see that from a
world champion magnus just took a pawn
but now black will play bishop takes
bishop and black will be a piece up for
free and win the game so magnus just
resigns what is up with the world
champion this is a
huge development eric hansen the second
lowest ranked player in the tournament
the chess dreamer has just beaten with
the black pieces the world champion and
magnus is still sitting looking at this
what is he thinking david i don't know
he must have been really surprised and
shocked with himself because it appears
like he hallucinated something yeah
sometimes we talk about chest blindness
sometimes you just make assumptions you
just forget about something for example
maybe here he just forgot his bishop
could be captured by the black light
squared bishop and he's just a piece
down um something just went wrong in his
calculations there maybe that was on his
mind but he just played it in the wrong
order that can happen too sometimes
that's the second move in your mind but